and there are people who say to this day  Trump never denounced white supremacists  and neo-nazis I yeah I know that you're  right and it just blows my mind the the  that the video of him saying that is out  it exists it's out there and and it has  been put onto Twitter saying oh he never  condemned them in response so many times  and they still oh he never did there are  still people I meet where I say did you  know that Joe Biden said if you don't if  you don't find the prosecutor you're not  getting a billion dollars they go that  never happened that absolutely happens  it's a video he says it's literally in a  in a like Think Tank press conference on  Foreign  Relations sitting there literally  talking to him on record on video and  he's like and people applaud but but  Rachel Maddow said it wasn't real and so  people just believe whatever she says  without even bothering to to look yeah  that's that's it's a crazy reality man